[Musique]
en analyse avec Jimmy Jean ce soir
vice-président économiste en chef
stratège au Mouvement Desjardins bonsoir
alors d'entrée de jeu comment vous
analysez cet essoufflement de
l'inflation au Canada
évidemment mais il faut regarder
vraiment les points positifs puis outre
les sens une très forte diminution dans
l'essence on voit quand même qu'il y a
des catégories de dépenses plus
discrétionnaire par exemple les voyages
où on voit des baisses on va aussi par
exemple tout ce qui avait été fortement
influencé par la pandémie par exemple
les véhicules récréatifs très forte
baisse là-dedans aussi donc on commence
à avoir des petits signes que justement
le repli des consommateurs le fait que
les consommateurs doivent être beaucoup
plus prudents avec leur ménage qu'on
diminue les dépenses non essentielles
mais c'est en train d'influencer les
certaines catégories d'inflation donc il
reste que on est encore à 6,3%, il y a
encore un long chemin à faire mais ça
commence petit à petit à apparaître de
manière générale on soulignait
aujourd'hui à Statistique Canada qui a
une bonne partie du RA de l'inflation
qui s'explique par l'énergie par les
prix de l'essence et en contrepartie on
le voyait avec Marie-claude les prix à
l'épicerie ce sont des produits
essentiels on y échappe pas on doit
continuer de manger ça grimpe toujours
de manière soutenue est-ce que de
l'espoir de ce côté-là est-ce qu'on s'en
va sur la bonne voie oui mais pas tout
de suite c'est à dire que ce qu'on
regarde au niveau international au
niveau des prix des denrées on voit une
très forte diminution aux États-Unis
quand on regarde les PC pour les
aliments là aussi des variations
mensuelles ce sont beaucoup atténuées
donc ça ça nous indique que la variation
annuelle de l'inflation devrait se
calmer mais pour l'instant ça reste
encore très très élevé comme on l'a vu
et aussi ce qui est important parce
qu'on se fait beaucoup poser la question
par le membre et client est-ce que ça
veut dire que les prix vont revenir à où
ils étaient si on parle d'inflation qui
diminue c'est pas la même chose la
désinflation et la déflation précisez
nous parce que nous aussi on se fait
poser des questions Monsieur Jean
différence entre déflation et
désinflation alors c'est important pour
les gens qui nous écoutent de comprendre
que nous les économies ça va beaucoup
parler de l'inflation qui revenus à la
normale mais ça va pas vouloir
nécessairement dire que les prix vont
être devenus à revenus à la normale donc
c'est important de faire la distinction
des inflations on a plus d'une forte
croissance des prix mais on a quand même
les prix l'accumulation qu'on a eu au
cours de la dernière année qui va rester
parmi nous dans la plupart des cas
malheureuses normalement qu'est-ce qui
vient régler ça c'est quand les salaires
augmentent un rythme qui dépasse
l'inflation or en ce moment ce n'est pas
le cas ce n'est toujours pas le cas et
c'est ce qui fait en sorte qu'on parle
de pouvoir d'achat qui s'est érodé je
pense que malheureusement une partie de
cette érosion là sera permanente ou du
moins va rester avec nous pour un bon
bout de temps ce qui va demander
vraiment consommateur d'être très
prudent dans leur finance puisqu'on est
dans les détails un peu plus techniques
des inflation déflation est-ce que un
effet statistique dans les prochains
mois quand on va parler d'inflation
parce qu'à partir de février on va se
comparer à février 2022 au moment où les
prix de l'essence atteignaient des
sommets est-ce que c'est pour ça que
l'inflation pourrait être moins soutenue
dans les prochains mois exactement donc
moi je dis au sens large l'inflation
totale on va pas parler de déflation
mais il y a des composants oui on va
parler de déflation je pense que
l'essence est un exemple on va le voir
également dans les biens d'ailleurs aux
États-Unis qu'on regarde les tendances
actuelles dans les biens avec la
résolution des chaînes
d'approvisionnement effectivement et
aussi avec les inventeurs qui sont
élevés au niveau des détaillants il faut
s'attendre à ce que il y ait des baisses
de prix par rapport à l'année passée
donc ça va faire en sorte que on va
parler de déflation dans certaines
catégories mais ce sera pas assez pour
dire qu'on parle de déflation
généralisée pourquoi parce que les
services c'est vraiment qu'est-ce qui
compte c'est la grosse c'est le gros
poids dans le panier et les services
sont fortement influencés par les donc à
ce moment là on n'a pas ses effets
déflationnistes là on a plutôt pénurie
de main d'oeuvre qui se maintiennent qui
se poursuivent des salaires qui même
s'ils sont ils veulent pas au rythme de
l'inflation mais sont quand même en
accélération et ça ça continue de la
pression c'est ça on a 5,1 % le sur un
an pour le mois de décembre pour
l'augmentation des salaires dans quelle
mesure le repli actuel de l'inflation
Monsieur Jean est attribuable à l'effet
du resserrement de la politique
monétaire est-ce qu'on envoie déjà les
effets mais certainement pas les plains
effets exactement je pense que comment
savoir des petits signes parce que on le
sait dans l'enquête sur les perspectives
des entreprises qui sortira par la vente
du Canada c'est très clair et net les
consommateurs coupent dans leur dépense
non essentielles disent qu'ils vont
épargner plus qui vont rembourser de la
dette donc les effets sont là il y a un
changement de comportement et c'est
certain que ça va paraître dans les
chiffres d'inflation mais l'inflation sa
tendance à les changements de prix ça se
fait pas instantanément dans la plupart
des cas ça a tendance à prendre beaucoup
de temps il faut que les les entreprises
voient la faiblesse de la demande pour
dire bon mais c'est le temps peut-être
que je coupe mes prix parce que je
commence à perdre la demande d'ailleurs
on voit les entreprises de plus en plus
inquiète par rapport à la demande étant
donné ce qu'on vit donc ça aussi ça va
faire en sorte que pour protéger des
parts de marché certaines entreprises
vont devoir être concurrentiels baisser
les prix donc le processus il faut y
faire confiance il est en train de
marcher mais il prend toujours un
certain temps mais c'est pour ça que
nous on pense que la Banque du Canada
peut-être elle en a une petite dernière
pour la route là on peut dire la semaine
prochaine encore de points mais après ça
je pense qu'on est capable de dire on
est capable d'attendre puis mesurer
prendre la pleine mesure de ses effets
là parce que il y a certains économistes
qui avancent cette théorie qu'on serait
déjà en récession au Québec à tout le
moins est-ce que vous êtes de cet avis
on a des signes qui sont assez probants
là pour le Québec on a une contraction
du PIB au Québec au troisième trimestre
alors même que le Canada a eu une
expansion les indicateurs au niveau de
la consommation au niveau de la
confiance des sont très bas donc il y a
plusieurs facteurs variables qui
corroborent ça qu'on regarde le marché
d'habitation les mises en chantier donc
c'est pas juste une variable c'est
plusieurs variables qui nous disent que
oui vraiment il y a un ralentissement
c'est substantiel va falloir voir
maintenant si le 4e trimestre s'avère
une autre contraction à ce moment-là on
parlait de récession technique mais même
si on parle de récession technique qui
est important de mentionner c'est que le
marché de l'emploi lui se tient toujours
de manière rigoureuse et souvent c'est
ce qui fait la différence entre la
saison technique et une véritable
récession très bien Monsieur Jean merci
beaucoup encore une fois pour votre
analyse pour voir nos émissions en
entier rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI
[Musique]